hey friends welcome back to deep dive so
it's the end of season one this is the
first time officially that we're doing a
podcast and in this episode we're doing
a little bit of a round up of some of my
favorite slash most inspiring moments
from various guests of season one over
the last couple of months i have
interviewed slash had conversations with
12 different people on the podcast and
we're already well underway into
recording some of the interviews for
season two as well which is kind of fun
and it's just been super nice to have
the privilege to speak to these people
mostly in real life because in the past
i've done remote interviews but it's
just the vibes are so much better in
real life that's been really awesome and
to hear the response that you guys have
in the episode has been really cool as
well please do keep the nice comments
coming on youtube and on twitter
especially if you can leave a review on
apple podcasts i think probably the
biggest lesson that i've learned from
the people that i've interviewed is
about
embracing uncertainty i'm going through
a bit of like an uncertainty-ish time in
my life right now where i've just quit
being a doctor and i'm now trying to
figure out what the hell do i do with my
life and the good thing from basically
everyone that i've spoken to on the
podcast is that no one really knows what
they're doing they're all kind of making
up as they go along and one thing leads
to another leads to another and what a
lot of people have said is just that the
idea of having a plan and sticking to it
is kind of a bit of a myth especially in
this world as uh things change so much
and so
that's really been one of my key
takeaways just to be more embracing of
uncertainty and more like you know
i'll try and do my best with what's
with what's going on i would try and
enjoy the journey as much as possible
rather than being fixated on the
destination and
just kind of see see how things go and
just not be overly beating up of myself
if things don't follow a prescribed plan
that i may be made a few months ago or a
few years ago anyway we're not going to
include segments from six of the guests
that we've had on the podcast so far
we've got ben francis uh chrissy chella
chris williamson unj jade mr who's the
boss and dr grace lorden and these are
some of the clips that i found most
inspiring from season one so i hope you
enjoy them so you start off as like a
band of banded brothers like you know a
handful of people in a shed yeah a
radiator is a game-changing expense yeah
a game-changing addition to the business
and
now jim shark is a billion plus dollar
company you're the new ceo of it like
how many employees do you do you know uh
we're just over 700 700 and you sell all
of the world with offices all around the
world
that's got to feel pretty wild like cool
it's called honestly i still walk into
the hq so we've got a gorgeous hq and
there's of the big logo on the front
over the road we've got our lifting
clubs we've got like a gym manufacturing
facility studios
i do walk in and
like i do still get goosebumps because
it's it's such an amazing place and
there's a buzz like you've got to visit
because as soon as you walk in the door
there's a buzz there and everyone's
lovely everyone's pulling in the same
direction everyone really understands
why we do what we do
everyone understands the area that they
sort of fit in with that sort of wider
plan
it's it's such a lovely place to be
so
it's interesting you say that like
everyone's putting in the same direction
because i think i feel like
this is an issue we're having as we
expanded from three people to 12 people
whereby i'm now having starting to do
things like defining our vision and
where we want to be in x number of years
and kpis and goals and all this stuff
that in the past i would have thought
this is all just corporate [ __ ] like
who cares about any of that
um
presumably like like
what was your journey through kind of
being more businessy about it so what
you're going through yeah so we did that
i used to hate the word corporate and
you're going through for reading between
the lines what i actually think is the
most difficult change i think this is
one of the most difficult things for any
entrepreneur or business person and by
the way not even owning your own
business if you're running or working in
a great business it's so difficult to
sort of distribute that control and
i think those that can do that then
after that it's not playing sailing but
if you've then done that it's like you
know it's like a muscle memory right if
you continue to do that i think scaling
becomes so much easier
um i'll give you so my sort of breakdown
i sort of break it down into three areas
and i think every great business person
needs to reinvent themselves over and
over again so you can't become too like
tied in or emotionally attached to sort
of let me say who you are in many
respects so
at the start i found
i had a great creative vision i didn't
exist i had a great idea where i wanted
us to be and i i felt like i dragged the
business to where i wanted us to be and
that sounds a bit sort of direct but you
know it could be having a great creative
vision it could be great at knowing
products it could be great whatever it
is but
you because you tend to be a one-man
band or there's not many people involved
you just do what the hell you want when
you want and it's very instinctive
now you'll then get to a stage where
you've got people around you it might be
five people it might be 10 people it
might be 30 people and an instinctive
way of running things it's still great
but you can't just do things on a whim
because you fancy you have to then learn
to work in a team and i don't mean when
i say in a team i mean you are part of
the team and anyone that's managed a
team knows that the team doesn't work
for you you work for them and you need
to make sure that you're really
understanding how to work with each
different type of people's person so
some people will love to be organized
and they will love lots of different
catch-ups and you know some people will
be highly creative some people will be
highly logical some people you'll have
to spend six weeks trying to buy them
into a new new idea some people have to
spend six seconds and it's about
learning how to work with all these
different people so you've gone from
dragging the business to where you
wanted it to be learning to work with
new people and then
that's it sounds like to a degree what
you're going through slash the next
stage which is like okay you know how to
work with people
how do we galvanize them around a vision
or a mission how do we make them
understand where they fit in with that
how do we make them understand that
you know the team that we're working
with touch what is greater than the sum
of its parts and really understanding
how to articulate yourself and your
vision um
and essentially learning how to inspire
people and i think that's again it's
very tough and
i hear people a lot of the time saying
like
oh you know
one facet of their personality that's
just me what am i like i'm a bit
unorganized well
when you're at that level there's not
there's no excuse for being an organizer
like yes i am an organized but you do
something about it you either fix it
yourself or you build the team in a way
that negates that weakness does that
make sense
it's um i think it gets a bit more
serious at that point and yeah you have
to learn new skills and tourists that's
why i love the job so much and feel like
i've got the best job in the world
because you're constantly learning new
things and constantly reinventing
yourself let's say someone's watching
this and they're thinking they're they
want to get started being an
entrepreneur yeah maybe they're sort of
late teens early 20s haven't really
started anything yet but really inspired
by you and your journey any kind of
advice
you'd give yeah i mean it's fairly
standard right you have to do what you
love because otherwise you'll end up
you'll end up giving up um i'm a firm
believer now that there's no niche too
small especially with the internet being
so vast
i always think and it sounds stupid
saying it now if i'd have said as a kid
i want to be a professional gamer
growing up yeah my mom would have been
like you're nuts whereas now it's like a
legitimate sport career and everything
in between like even i guess with
yourself it would have been so difficult
for you to articulate what you do now as
a kid yeah i just think there's no need
too small so i think whatever it is
double down on it and just genuinely
give it a go like
gymshark was the seventh business
website product that i've made and the
other six failed miserably now
unfortunately that's not a sexy story so
no one talks about the failed apps the
failed websites they only talk about the
one that did well and
it's a consistent theme on everyone else
that's successful that i've met they've
failed miserably so many times and
they've been endlessly optimistic about
it and they've just gone again and again
and again in the book i think so it's
one of the early chapters you talk about
finding your why and you reference simon
sinek's book start with why um i wonder
w when it comes to
sort of new entrepreneurs or people
starting out in their entrepreneurship
or being a creator
to what extent do you think it's
important to start with
to start with that mission or purpose
because it's very important it's so
important it's so
important if you are
starting a brand if you want to start a
brand like if you don't know your why
just don't do it like i can't stress
that enough if you are starting a brand
to make money
oh like i don't know
okay no you should never start a brand
to make money
if your call if your if your core
ideology is profit
if your core
value is we aim to make
100 million in the first five years if
that's your number one core value i'm
not saying it shouldn't be a core value
i'm saying if that's your number one
core value you're going to plummet
because every decision you make will be
profit lead not mission led there's a
complete difference
so you need your why you need to know
why you want to start why you want to
start what is the reason and it's a very
big question to ask yourself because
you'll start understanding
that it's deeper than what you first
perceived when women come to me and go i
really want to lose 10 pounds i go why
yeah why do why tell me why because i
really want to know why
oh because i know i look better okay but
why does that matter i know i'll feel
better okay but why
but why but why truth is
that bride that wants to lose 10 pounds
for her wedding day
it's not that she wants to lose 10
pounds is that she wants to feel
confident in her wedding day so actually
it's not about the pounds she loses it's
the effort she's putting in daily to
feel confident on her wedding day
there's a complete difference so that y
is going to keep her driven longer than
constantly stepping on the scales and
seeing those numbers not shift yeah i
think it's similar on the let's say if
someone wants to start a youtube channel
if you if you do it for the sake of
wanting to make money from it
it's really hard to keep that motivation
going to sustain that if you do it for
the sake of chasing views it's really
hard to keep going but if you do it for
you get really sad
you're going to get really upset
you're going to think you're not good
enough you're going to cross compare
you're gonna just never be satisfied
i've been there like i can genuinely
speak from experience and you're going
to completely and truly [ __ ] your mind
up so one thing one thing i was
intrigued about was sort of your
one of your sort of life philosophies
that sounds like a grandiose way of
putting it but well one of your life
philosophies is that you don't see you
seem not
you seem to not care about goals
and that really resonates with me
because i also think goals are a bit
overrated and it's more about the
journey rather than about the
destination
um and that's something i've been i've
been like spilling on my youtube channel
for the last like four years and i read
that
in the book you said something along
that effect as well that like you know
it's it's less about the destination
it's not about like the motivation it's
not about the goal
motivation is so overrated like
what oh she's just like jarring and just
just like shut up like i hate her she's
she comes one day she leaves another day
she's there in a moment and then i'm
like where is she gone and then it's
just like
i can't be bothered with it and i can't
express enough how you need to stop
relying on motivation and start relying
more on building consistency and
discipline in your day-to-day life
motivation is not something that you can
sustain for the rest of your life
because there's going to be moments
where you don't want to get out of bed
there's going to be moments where you
want to eat your favorite pizza and
watch netflix and skip the gym totally
fine there's going to be moments where
you actually don't want to come to work
even though it's your biggest passion
because you're tired you're drained
you're exhausted mentally and physically
but consistency is what makes you go
i'm going to go to the gym
but i'm going to come back home also and
eat my pizza and watch netflix with my
partner
i'm going to go to work but only for two
hours
you know it's it's that's what
consistency is to me
okay because it's sort of like showing
up showing up yeah because
motivation to me is either all
okay yeah i need a motivator to go for
that five characters oh i don't go
like yeah yes okay consistency to me is
if i don't want to do it one day i'll go
for a little bit okay i'll give it a go
yep if i don't want to show up fine i'll
take my meetings from home
it's more flexible
okay it's more understanding
and i see these components as actual
humans that sounds really weird but
i see motivation as like this sassy diva
she sometimes wants to to go on stage
and give her best show but sometimes she
just wants to tell a team to go away and
she's not going on stage
then i see consistency as like this
really like humble
genuine
person that wants to help you
and i think you should people need to
start perceiving certain elements as
personas because it will make you kind
of
distinguish which one you want to aim
for more yeah which one you want to
build a relationship with more
interesting okay so it's
it's you wake up in the morning your
alarm goes about half past five and
you're thinking oh i'm feeling a bit
tired today
what do you what do you tell yourself to
this was the other day for me actually i
my alarm went off at half five
ironically and then i was like oh it's
cold it's dark i'm in england
like it's too cold now yeah it's like
nearly november and i was like i'm so
tired i don't want to go to the gym
and then i said to myself
right listen chrissy
go to the gym today
if you'd feel like this tomorrow give it
a miss
that's what i said to myself like and i
did today i didn't go to the gym i
didn't go to the gym i was still so
tired i gave myself an extra two hours
sleep instead
and that's what i needed yeah but if i'm
doing that every day
that's not good here's a question for
you man yeah do you think that people
love you for what you do or for who you
are
i've been
so over the last few months i i really
thought it was for what i do especially
when it came to friend friendship and
stuff
um i thought that
i just didn't quite
i thought it was the things that i was
doing um
that were the reasons why people wanted
to be friends with me and it was
it was surprising when i mentioned this
to a few friends and they were like
no you actually don't need to do any
like
because
if i think about
the people i'm friends with i'm not
friends with them for what they do i'm
friends with who they are and it took
other people pointing out to me that
well that's how other people feel about
you for me to think oh my god and that
was quite like a a profound realization
for me and made me realize that i can
just sort of be myself but in the but
before i'd been like uh be yourself it's
all just bs because like choose yourself
and and all that kind of stuff i got
another question yeah do you love
yourself for who you are or for what you
do
oh good question i think i love myself
for what i do yeah so here's the problem
right
we want the world to love us for who we
are not for what we do we don't want
people to love our achievements we want
to feel like we're worth something
ourselves yep
however we love ourselves
for what we do not who we are so we're
asking the world to do something that we
don't do ourselves i want you to love me
for who i am not what i do
meanwhile i'mma love myself for what i
do not who i am because i feel like when
i achieved something that i feel like
i'm worth something more to myself when
i hit that next subscriber count when i
get that
gold plaque
diamond plaque when i hit a new best
number of plays when i get more people
on my academy when i put more people
into my club night when i sleep with a
more popular girl when i hit a new
number of
followers on instagram
all of these different metrics are
things that are hiding the fact that we
don't want to give ourselves self love
for what it is that we who we genuinely
are what do what do you mean by love
yourself
feel comfortable and feel like you are
sufficient
independent
of how you perform day-to-day in the
world
the fact that you
stripped of all of your achievements
youtube channel's gone podcast's gone
degrees are gone all of that stuff are
you isolated and stripped bear still
worth something to the world and do you
feel like people would still love you
and still care about you that's a good
question
it's a difficult one it's a very
different one so i got that realization
from aubry marcus another this anyone
that's resonating with this i'll give
you the link for this episode with aubry
he's just sold on it to unilever for a
huge undisclosed number like hundreds of
millions of dollars right
the link will be in the show notes below
he said
he'd bolstered his entire life with sex
and money so he'd spent his entire life
chasing women and trying to earn
he's just sold his company for a hundred
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars and he's just got married
what's left for him all of the things
that he used to be chasing now he's
completed them and he had an existential
crisis
because he said all of these things that
i thought would fulfill me i've now done
it
so who am i i'd wrapped up so much of my
self-worth in the fact that i was
chasing this dream dragon of a woman and
of a
figure in my bank account
and now it's got to the stage where
actually who am i without all of that
or who am i once all of that's been
completed and this comes back to
what happened when
i first started a business and again
this is
another element for young business
people
if you attach your sense of self-worth
to the success of the business
you are on a path toward misery the
reason is that
you don't get to control the [ __ ]
market right the market will do what the
market will do and it does not give one
single [ __ ] about you it doesn't care so
why would you say that your self-worth
is based on
trends in the market you're literally
externalizing your sense of well-being
to other people
that's the same as that's the same as
people that leave notifications on their
phone
it's exactly the same okay you're
allowing the entire world anybody on the
planet to intrude on your day whenever
they want this is the same with your
business you're allowing the response of
the market to determine your self-worth
every time that you put a product out or
run an event or release a youtube video
if you feel crap when your youtube video
underperforms but feel amazing when your
youtube video over performs that's fine
that's
realistic
you care about performing well but if
you genuinely feel like you are worth
more
or worth less
that's a different step you've crossed a
line there and this is something that i
still fight with all the time i still
struggle with it this is me
understanding the path but not having
completed the path
so you're on this kind of uh 12 to 18
month journey of self-discovery and you
said that one of the things that helped
is asking yourself
is this thing that i'm doing consistent
with the person that i want to be yes um
what were some other things that you
figured out about yourself along that
that path not telling the truth was it
was a huge one um i'd just been
people would ask me my opinion on
something and i would tell them what i
thought they wanted to hear okay not
what i genuinely believed because i
presumed that that would make them like
me because i just wanted to be liked and
this was funded or fueled by being a
club promoter which is very transient
and transactional and there is a degree
of performative
uh nature on the front door of a club
night if someone says all right mate how
are you and you go well actually man my
dog just died and blah blah blah they're
like no i just want you to say yes and
give me a stamp and go let me in so
there is
that was reinforced by work
some of the other things were mostly to
do with opening up and being being
vulnerable because i was
in a
hyper masculine
very cool guy world
and
it wasn't
it wasn't uh
how would you say conducive to
having a bad day and opening up to
someone about it it's another challenge
as well for anyone that's a business
owner or at the top of the tree that's
listening
you can feel like because you are the
head of your business
that showing any form of weakness shows
a weakness in the business that if you
underperform or you have a bad day that
the people who look up to you your
subordinates and your employees within
the business
will see you
as less will see you as unworthy of
leading them because who's whose leader
would spend a couple of days in bed
because he's feeling down about whatever
might have occurred um
another thing that i realized was
working
working so hard
that you have a miniature breakdown
which for me manifested is being in bed
for a couple of days and i just
couldn't be bothered to get out and it
felt like depression but i think it was
just
like
small acute breakdowns
it always happened around freshers week
so
one month of constant build up constant
and this is when i'd stop partying so
much as well
releasing event after event after event
all on social media then going and
working on the night
four or five hours sleep then get up the
next day go to the office make sure that
everything was sorted run another event
fill it cash the tills go home do the
next thing oh is this working this djs
cancel blah blah blah just constant
intensity
start of october every single year i
would always spend a couple of days in
bed why why is it that i always end up
feeling a little bit sort of shitty
after this
because
going so hard that you end up snapping
is not a sustainable
work protocol just
doesn't it you can't keep doing that and
expect to get consistent results
and
punishing yourself because you don't
have the tolerance it's like having eyes
that are bigger than your stomach it's
like having an appetite for work which
is bigger than your capacity for work
and this is something in a productivity
world look i'll get more i'll just get
more done um
that is a route toward disaster for
chris sparks says in order to pick
something up you have to put something
down and the presumption is
if i want to be more productive
i will just down regulate my sleep or up
regulate my efficiency until i fit this
new thing in yeah
but you're already working close to your
maximum capacity because if you weren't
you would be doing more
most people that are driven type a
personalities are already working close
to their capacity and then when you
because you see all of your own
inefficiencies right you think yeah but
i spent 30 minutes a day on youtube so
if i add this new thing in i'll just get
rid of that 30 minutes it's like no the
30 minutes a day on youtube is there
because you need a [ __ ] break from
all the work you're doing
that's going to stay when you add this
in the place it's going to come off of
is going to be optional things that
really matter like spending time with
friends and family like chilling out on
a weekend like getting more sleep that's
what's going to really really sting
so those are some of the realizations
work less open up more be truthful
realize that you have curiosities and
intellectual desires and stuff that
maybe don't align with the person that
you thought you were because you've
talked in a few videos about like
manifestation and stuff like what
or what is that so
i've read the secret uh i haven't read
the scene okay cool
and everyone everyone i've i've heard
everyone i've heard speak about the
secret does it in very like disparaging
terms like well there's all this
manifestation
it's all like bs um but you like talk
about it sincerely yeah or it seems to
be like what is manifestation to you and
yeah how does it manifest in your life
as it were um okay so to me it's kind of
common sense okay
in in a way if you want something
you're gonna have to say it out loud
you're gonna have to take actions
towards it and you're also gonna
probably need a bit of luck because
that's how life works and that's kind of
common sense you know like if you want a
certain job if you want to be a doctor
you first got to decide that's something
you really want you've got to be very
specific say okay i probably in the next
five years i'm gonna have to apply for
med school i'm probably gonna want to go
to maybe this university then you can
say it out loud you can write it down it
becomes kind of a clearer thought um and
then you have to use wait let me say
that again
just through yeah like putting it down
on paper you're already thinking about
actions of how you're going to go
towards that whether that's like working
harder for certain grades and then the
element of luck
that i guess the law of attraction comes
into you know you can call it
synchronicity you can call it luck you
can call it the universe you can call it
whatever you want to but there's always
an element of that okay um so the law of
attraction is that to me it's you decide
something and you get really clear on
what it is you want and then you can
also assist that thing with
visualizations like the more you can
picture yourself
having that thing the more likely you
are to have it just because you're going
to shape your actions towards also
getting it
so what would the the visualization
thing look like yeah um so i think this
falls into realm of meditation for
example like closing your eyes i i think
about this with an exam like the night
before an exam if you close your eyes
and you picture yourself from the exam
hall
most people
first thing you think of is stress
you know you're like flicking through
the paper you've got no time and you're
kind of manifesting that version of you
being stressed without you doing
anything about it
so in order for you to do the opposite
you'd have to visualize yourself being
there being calm being rational being
focused and like you know feeling quite
confident kind of fake it till you make
it and the more that you picture that
imagine yourself in it yeah then the
more likely you are to borrow from that
visualization and naturally do it so
yeah it's kind of just imagining the
best case scenario but that makes you
more likely to also do that scenario
okay
does that make sense
yeah it does um
i feel like i sometimes accidentally do
this without realizing i'm doing this
um
there was this guided meditation thing i
did the other day uh
which was sort of about imagining your
life
some years in the future what does your
house look like what does the family
look like what are you spending your
time doing and before doing it i was
like oh this is going to be some stupid
meditation thing yeah and then and
then i did it it was like 20 minutes and
i was like oh wow i've just never spent
any time thinking what could my life
look like in the future and i had like a
very specific
sort of
vision of
what like my future house might look
like and you know i was like oh you know
in this in this vision like you know the
wife is tucking the two kids into bed
there's like a third one on the way
we've got a little fireplace i've got
like my little desk in the corner that
has like an imac on it or whatever it's
like a guitar i've been playing the
guitar it's like a dog and it's like oh
this is kind of nice and since doing
that like last week
i have been thinking back to that
and thinking oh i wonder what sort of
dog i want like it's just like
just random
i very rarely think what sort of dog
going on in the future but the fact that
i had that i did that visualization
thing is now like a thing where i feel
like oh yeah i'm definitely gonna get a
dog in the future that's so cool um
and so
i don't know i feel like i want to do
more in the way of like this sort of
vision boarding e type stuff
that's awesome i've already got around
yeah that's basically what the law of
attraction is or at least the way i
think about it it's just getting clear
on your vision for your life which we
don't do enough and i don't i'm not
clear on that but as soon as you know
you start to have an idea it does sort
of work its way into your mind more and
then you're more likely to make it
happen would you be open to sharing some
of the things in your vision board or is
it like a a private thing
it's kind of private because i don't
know like if this is actually what i
want okay no fair enough
um have you found the manifesting stuff
helping another aspect of life as well
um
like in yeah i think in terms of
confidence oh okay why does it like you
imagine yourself as being more confident
exactly you are more confident yeah that
makes a lot of sense yeah right like
again that's how you get until you make
it yeah
okay or even for example with the book
like when i was writing this book when i
had to go down and sit down and you know
was dreading the writing process
visualizing myself as someone who had
written the book who had finished it and
was receiving a nice review from someone
about how it helped them but not in like
a stressful way just like oh you know
that was this was clearly helpful to
them things like that you know it just
helps you then find that motivation to
sit down and write okay that's very
interesting
and do you do do you do this like
actively do you have like a slot in your
calendar for like manifesting time or
like how does it work within your life
because i have a solid routine of
meditation
some of those meditations i choose to do
on that day could be in the realm of
manifestation okay so you type in
manifestation meditation on youtube and
someone will give you a guided tour
exactly oh okay yeah so i guess that
that must have been that thing that i
did the other day which is just like
someone talking about like
close your eyes imagine yourself five
years from now yeah think about the
sounds think about the feelings that
kind of stuff and you can just imagine
if you did that meditation every day
like every day you sort of add to that
vision
yeah definitely you're like oh i have a
dog and like oh i'm starting to see like
a poodle you know like would i like a
food on the next day you do the
meditation you're like actually no it's
like golden retriever yeah
okay that's interesting because i guess
in my head meditation is like you sit
there doing nothing for
example i think most people think that
there's so many different types like
visualizations meditations there are
like breathing frameworks um just being
present and you know hearing everything
around you engaging with your senses
okay there's loads and you don't need to
i guess again when it comes to
meditation i think i overthink it and
like uh i need to find the perfect like
puff whereas it sounds like we're eating
just like type in some random meditation
on youtube depending on what you're
feeling and just go for it exactly and
that's
like obviously good for you yeah and
because i know that the practice of
meditation generally is good it doesn't
really matter what it is like just
closing my eyes and like forcing myself
to breathe for like five to ten minutes
i'm showing up like i'm doing the work
you know it doesn't need to be like a
perfect meditation every day and if i
like it can do it again i don't look at
my metrics at all so i would love to
learn from you about like what can i be
doing how much time do you spend in the
youtube analytics i look at it for every
single video that i post so two days
after it's gone live i'll kind of i'll
spend a good half an hour just going
through it being like what countries did
this hit how long did those people stay
on for when did the majority drop off
was there a significant spike or a
significant dip did certain parts make
people go back
um things like that
because you can see all of it it's like
why wouldn't you
well you don't but i think you should
yeah i really think i should as well
like yeah so i found things like for
example if i asked people to subscribe
really early in the video it was
detrimental because you'd get um
a drop of like 20 of viewers potentially
but
they wouldn't be subscribing they'd just
be irritated by the fact you've asked
them to subscribe without showing them
why yeah
because at the start of a video in the
first like 15 seconds people are very
very easy to lose
it's at that point that they decide
whether they're going to you know full
screen you and kind of invest in this
video or whether they're going to you
know click on one of the 30 that are
kind of grabbing their attention from
the side how how should i start
if i if i if you're like if you were
like kind of my youtube mentor or
whatever like how would you advise me to
start looking at retention graphs and
analytics a bit more what's what's like
a good a good starting point
um i would look for troughs so look at
kind of points where you've got
viewers that are stable and then when
they go down
and try to identify why they've gone
down at that point so for example one of
the other things i found was like
i would do a round off at the end of a
video and at the point where you start
rounding off a video anyone who feels
like they've got it they're like okay
i'm done this is the end of the video
and so instead what i've started doing
is the the second i finish the key
content
i'm talking about the next video
so it's literally like and that's what
happened to samsung okay for the video
on this that's there for the video on
this that's there yeah and i found
immediately that like the amount of
clicks i was getting on my end cards to
lead to the next video where like they
tripled
and so my outro now has my face in it it
didn't used to have my face in it it
just used to be this kind of blaring
music but now it feels like a
continuation of the main content yeah
and i'm kind of being like look over
there look over there and they can see
me pointing to videos
um
and i think actually i think you said
this once uh not that long ago actually
that the people who watch till the end
are the most valuable audience members
because they're more likely to follow
through right yeah yeah so the the the
end card thing is something that we
started doing as well uh about about a
year ago and it worked really nicely but
kind of beyond that i didn't really
i don't really look at the numbers
because it's scary it's yeah it's scary
it also feels like and i don't know if
this is a relic of my kind of olden days
of like just i think i have to drink the
consistency kool-aid way too much where
it's like once you made a video then
forget about the video on to the next
one
um and
the kind of one percent improvements
over time
i think i've been doing from my own gut
of like oh it would be cool if the next
video had this thing
and especially when i was editing my own
videos that was a lot easier to do now
that there's like a layer between me and
the video being edited it's actually
harder especially because our editor
question is in romania
it's it's it's a lot harder to effect
change
even with the whole remote thingy and
even with like frame io and all this all
this other stuff that i'm now even
thinking to the point of like let's get
christian to switch to final cut pro so
he can send me the project file and i
can i can do the final cut myself um so
that i can then have more finely tuned
control over what's going on in the
video i can understand that like i've
not still fully handed off stuff that i
probably should have handed off because
it's your baby right it's your face it's
your voice it's your it's your name
um so i understand that um but to be
honest i've actually benefited a lot
from having two people it's not a big
team but two people who are specialists
in their area and who like i can hand
things to and i know they'll do them
better than i would okay well what does
your team look like right now so it's
editor camera guy
okay it's very very basic but it's my
camera game editor they're very very
good at their jobs to the point where
i'm like if i've got any piece of
graphics i want doing i will consult
them because i know that they'll know
better than me
oh how long have you had those guys fall
uh editor for about three years camera
guy for about a year
do you do any of the editing yourself
now i do as a last resort if there's
like something really urgent which there
does tend to be with tech like you know
if apple does an event you want to react
to it you're editing that video um
because you can't ask your employees to
stay up all night although they do that
actually voluntarily but i don't ask
them um
but yeah so i'll do it if i have to
and like well one thing that really
strikes me about your videos is that
basically every second there is
something going on and i can't help but
continuing to watch it and then the meta
part of me is thinking
ah i love like all of these different
things that are going on to make me
encourage and encourage me to keep
watching this and the content itself is
very valuable
and so i think one thing that we do well
on this on on my channel is that the
content is broadly valuable but we do
basically nothing when it comes to the
visual side of things and it may as well
be a podcast yes and i think like that
anytime i see one of your videos i feel
like ridiculously inspired like oh my
god like the amount of post production
that's gone into this it's insane it's a
kind of the the way i describe it is a
an aggregation of micro refinements
so it's like
all that stuff hasn't happened overnight
if you kind of go back through the
channel and watch one video every year
you'd see a few new things each time so
like the day that i decided okay i'm
gonna spend more time on music and try
to create moods with what i'm saying the
day i decided to put my face in a circle
so i'm visible at all times
um and we've tried these experiments
looked at those graphs seen that they've
worked and then realized okay these are
mainstays data is is it like
you have a gut feeling that when i put
my face on the thing while showing
overlay it will work and then you
actually and then you look at the data
or yeah yeah exactly that so you have a
gut feeling you try it it works or it
doesn't work and then you action it and
how can you how can you tell like you
adding your face versus not adding a
face it's not like you're releasing the
same video face no face so you have a
control
it's tough but like
i think when you spend that much time
with the data you have a gauge on how
well a certain video will keep people
okay so for example i know that if i
make a camera comparison
they don't have good retention like an
average camera comparison might have 45
50 retention okay right and so if you do
a camera comparison and it gets 55
you're like that is an outlier
okay or if i do an unboxing or a top 10
if i do a top 10 that's going to get
really good retention and so you'll know
what to expect and in your top tens you
start out or you start from number 10
rather than number one always and
you go so something like you know and it
starts off it starts with a and then
becomes b and then becomes positively c
and it's like it's all so
it's just so clever
i spend a lot of time on the scripts um
and the other thing i do actually is
when i'm scripting i'm thinking of three
different people okay so there's three
people i know in my life of different
levels of i guess tech enthusiasm and so
with every line
i've almost reached the stage where i'm
scanning it being like is this
interesting to all these three people
would they watch this would they watch
this would they watch this would they
understand this is this funny to them
all that kind of stuff
and i think when you do that you end up
with a script that is a little more
broadly appealing than it would
otherwise be
how much time do you spend on scripting
that's that's most of what i do
okay so like for a standalone let's say
for uh a kind of google pixel versus
iphone 13 pro camera comparison 22
minute long video so that would is it 22
minutes yeah
um i think that was probably three and a
half days of scripting three and a half
days yeah
like are we talking eight hour days
no we're talking like 14 hour days we're
talking like
for 42 hours spent on scripting a single
video ages and eight months ages because
i do
the initial kind of like what i think is
gonna happen yeah then i test the phones
and kind of like because remember like
what i'm saying
i am having to create my own findings
i'm not taking things and like doing you
know passing them on yeah so you have to
make sure for every single thing you say
it is correct
and that that is one thing that i almost
wouldn't i wouldn't trust anyone else
with because it's my name and my type of
secret source as well yeah yeah so i
know how to test these products but it
takes time
bloody hell
what about for like a a stand like you
see
so you did a video that was um
ways in which tech is bad uh or
i'm worried about yes yeah that was a
bit of a departure from your phones it
was vibe yeah um you're not gonna like
this
it took about eight days of scripting i
think
so about 100 hours of scripting
something like that yeah i wasn't i
wasn't keeping track but it was a long
time
it's the kind of time that like the
practical part of me is thinking like
is this time well spent
um but sometimes i kind of like i get
carried away thinking about how viewers
are going to think you know i'm thinking
about these three different categories
of viewers and
um
and then sometimes scripts get away away
from you it's like okay this should be a
12 minute video and then you actually
try and do it and you're like oh my god
that's 25 26 minutes
um so sometimes things add up out of
your control
and i don't tamper them because
sometimes i'm like
it's okay this is going to be a big
project this is going to do really well
over time it's going to hit the youtube
criteria it's fine we'll spend more time
on it tell me more about your about your
process for videos like i'm going to i'm
going full selfish murder i just want to
i just want to learn from you here so
before
i think most youtubers
when you reach a certain size you start
planning videos backwards so when you
think about a video thinking about
thumbnail title would people click on it
um and then from there you're like okay
what's the content going to be like is
it engaging is it delivering value will
people finish that video thinking whoa i
like this guy and then at that point
then you're thinking you take a step
further back it's like okay what's the
storyline what's the subplot how are you
keeping people throughout that video
engaged and then you work all the way
back and then that's the point where
you've got your content you know what
your next step is but the way the normal
the trigger point is either an idea i've
had embedded
or some past video that did really well
that people really enjoyed and they're
like can we have a part two yeah or
something someone else has done that i
think that's a really interesting idea
what if i applied it to phones or you
know gadgets or whatever i really got a
sense that there was a storyline because
you were like i'm gonna tell you about
this product but there's like
but but there's a question here like
who's it for and it was like you were
you kept on that was like a thread going
through going through the content
and all that stuff is the stuff that you
do
in your kind of multiple passes of
figuring out
it's almost like writing a book it is
in my head like i never thought i'd
write as much as i do
like when i was a kid i thought i'll be
doing something where i'm working on an
excel spreadsheet or something it didn't
occur to me that my job is basically
video essays i started listening to your
book about four or five days ago and the
very first chapter talks about this idea
of me plus um i wonder if you're gonna
like elaborate like what does what does
me plus mean
so if you i mean if you go back to the
economics we're really good i think at
making at helping ourselves in the
present day so we know what makes us
happy in the moment but very often the
things that we have to invest in to give
our future selves a better future we
don't often do so what i like people to
do is to think about where would they
like to be if it all worked out so if
they threw out you know lost aversion if
they threw out fear of failure where
will they actually end up being and have
that be their me plus but before they
commit to that being their me plus
really think about what will that mean
plus actually do because i've noticed a
lot of times when i talk to people about
careers they're attached to a label so
they want to be a trader or an
investment banker or they want to be a
doctor
or they're attached to a lifestyle so
they want to be able to go on a
particular vacation or buy a particular
car and kind of think big journey is
really thinking about if i were to be a
doctor if i were to be a trader what
would be the tasks that i would be doing
on a day-to-day basis and would i
ultimately end up enjoying those tasks
so the activities that i'm going to
spend the time in
and there's two reasons for that so one
it makes you happier to actually do
tasks that you like which feels like a
no-brainer but secondly if you're
engaged in tasks that you like you tend
to be more successful and it's the
second that i'm really interested in and
kind of getting people into jobs where
they feel that they've reached the
success that they want okay
interesting and do you think
when it comes to being engaged in tasks
that you like some people say it's a
case of
find the thing that fits within your
values your personality and when once
you find that thing then you'll find it
fun and then there's another school of
thought that says well you know the
whole finding something that you're
passionate about is actually kind of
hard to do so
think about the stuff that you're
actually doing and find ways to make it
more interesting for yourself uh how how
do you how do you feel about those two
different different camps
i don't really feel that they're
different so you know so so people are
claiming now that they choose companies
based on the values the companies might
have and i think that's true in the same
way that we choose a company based on a
salary but when you're actually in the
job what tends to matter with respect to
productivity and happiness is how you
feel in those tasks in that moment and
if i'm working for a company that's
saving the environment but i've been
treated really badly in a microculture
in order to save that environment
there's a couple of companies come to
mind when i think about that um then i'm
not going to be productive and i'm not
going to be happy i'm actually likely to
leave that that job so it's more about
going beyond thinking what is the
company's mission what is my personality
and what is the micro culture of the
team that i'm going to be working in and
will that make me happy will i be
connected to the mission because my team
is connected to the mission
it's very hard to assess in advance when
you're applying for a job it's really
hard it is it's really really hard and i
think then if you bring it down to the
tasks and asking at an interview what
will i be doing on a day-to-day basis
um so when i come to work for you ali
what would i be doing on a day-to-day
basis as part of your team um so if you
could imagine me on a monday how will i
spend my time
the fact that you as a manager have
taught about that firstly will tell me
that you're a good manager because
you'll know actually what you want the
person to do um and you're not just
hiring blindly but the second is having
that information allows me to make my
mind up because if the if i like the
tasks i'm probably going to like the
team okay yeah that's very interesting
so that was a big part of the message i
took away from the me plus stuff and the
way it it manifested in my life when i
read it i was i was thinking okay you
know let's engage with this like what's
what's kind of what does me plus look
like and initially i was thinking oh you
know i'd really like to have six-pack
abs and then i came across a bit where
you were like no no forget about that
focus on like what what did the tasks
look like and i was like okay you know
what what i want me plus to do is to be
able to exercise every day and to have
fun doing it yeah um and so for the last
four days i've actually been to the gym
i went to a yoga class yesterday morning
i did a workout at like 8am this morning
and i i've never really done this sort
of thing but i was like excited about
that
i i was excited that the end goal was
not six plus six-pack abs i was excited
that the end goal was that in a way
there wasn't an end goal and it was a
case of just i want to be able to enjoy
this um is that the sort of thing that
you get a lot when you're doing this
sort of research that process rather
than outcome kind of thing so i kind of
write a lot for kind of people who might
not have made it yet or people who have
plateaued so if you if you take the
exercising analogy from somebody who's
contemplating doing the kind of a 5k run
rather than somebody who is
contemplating doing the london marathon
and is really well placed for that
and i think for the person who hasn't
done exercise for a while or the person
who hasn't really invested in their
career for a while the worst thing they
can do is do too much so if you hadn't
invested for a while the worst thing you
could do is go to the gym for three
hours you might get through it today but
the chances of repeating that are really
really small and i think kind of the one
of the big powerful messages underlying
anything big is whether you're focused
on your health or whether you're focused
on your career it's those small actions
that you take today will determine
yourself in two years time three years
time in four years time and actually by
throwing out the idea that you're going
to reinvent yourself in 30 days is
really really powerful because you're
much more likely to stick to it you know
you can accomplish an extraordinary
amount in 12 months very little in you
know 12 minutes or you know a very short
period of time you know i've been making
videos semi-themed around productivity
for the last four years and a big chunk
of the advice boils down to
consistency and just showing up and
taking small actions repeatedly and in a
way not really worrying so much about
the ultimate goal
um and these days i teach i uh teach
courses helping people become like
youtubers and stuff and and the way you
become a successful youtuber is you just
make one or two videos every week for
the next like five years um but no one
sticks with it for that long because
they have like the oh i must hit a
certain subscribe account i must hear a
certain like view count and my view on
this is that having like in a way those
outcome metrics the ones that are
outside of our control are kind of
unhelpful especially at the start of a
journey do you have any thoughts on on
that point well when you were talking it
actually reminded me i watched a video
of yours on compounding so when people
are choosing to invest
we accept compounding very very easily
right so we accept the idea actually
that you know if we leave money in for a
very long period of time it's going to
compound so we're probably going to be
okay in our pensions and it's exactly
the same here when it comes to your
career like those very small things that
you're going to do today and i ask for a
commitment of 90 minutes a week which
for most people regardless of how
pressurized you feel is very very
possible um that should compound once
you do once you've chosen tasks that
align with your me plus
relatively quickly okay 90 minutes a
week that's like 13 minutes a day ish
yes very doable
um one one bit that i was gonna ask you
about that i i thought maybe i disagreed
with was you talk like the title of the
book is think big yeah and the vibe i
got from the chapter around goals is
that you're keen on people setting
or
perhaps not but like
one camp of people in the sphere is
encouraging people to set these big
hairy audacious goals
and then figuring out the small steps
taken you can you can take to get there
but then there's another camp and this
is sort of where
where i think i am whereby
i think
in a way i feel maybe setting goals is a
bit overrated because if you're setting
a goal then
you're
essentially to me that feels like a
contract to be unhappy until you hit the
goal and then you hit the goal and you
have this like fleeting sense of like oh
i hit a million subscribers cool yep
you know my day to day hasn't really
changed et cetera et cetera so the way i
kind of think about goals is i try and
throw goals out of the window and
instead just focus on those like what do
i actually want to do but i don't know
if i'm just like bsing myself and like
you're doing okay so
that seems to be working for you i mean
i think so so for people who read the
book the goal is really there to serve
two purposes
so one so that you start investing in
your career so it helps to find the
tasks this week
and two so that you actually bring your
future self forward so you're not always
investing in activities that just serve
you in the present day but in the book i
do talk about the idea that every um
sunday so every kind of well i i pick
sundays it's the start of my week that
you reflect on how the week previous
went and you look to see whether or not
there are new opportunities that you
should be pivoting your goal for
so i see the think big part of the book
as really giving people a direction so
they can set off on a journey and they
start walking and more interesting
things might actually come along but
they make a conscious decision to follow
those interesting things so then they go
off on a slightly different journey so
if you take your own career for example
it was probably a great idea that you
studied medicine in cambridge right and
now you have an entirely different
career but you are using some of the
skills that you actually learned in the
university so in that particular case
you would have sat back and said
actually do i really want to pivot and
do a large pivot and the answer would
have been yes but had you never gone
into medici
medical school maybe you would never
have started walking in this direction
and come to the destination so it's
really about movement oh okay that's
really interesting um i was having these
thoughts i was it was a few weeks ago
and i was on a date and we went we were
kind of driving around afterwards just
like chatting and i was kind of thinking
that like driving around without a
destination it's just like if it felt a
bit wrong and so i just put the
destination of the like the mcdonald's
drive through in the sat nav and it
wasn't really about the destination it
was about okay i've got a destination
now
now i know what th what what the journey
is
and when we got to the mcdonald's
drivers like whatever it's mcdonald's
right through like that the destination
is actually not that important but the
point is i was thinking huh maybe having
the destination
lets you kind of set the direction for
your journey and then you can always
change your mind as you as you go
further down the line
and as humans we love certainty so even
if we've created for ourselves this is
the goal that we're moving towards then
we change our mind for the period of
time that we're moving there is
certainty one of the biggest things that
hampers people's growth and you know
stops them kind of getting to the place
where they probably deserve to be is
that they feel that the journey is
actually uncertain so by kind of having
that destination allows you to kind of
to move towards it oh okay yeah this
reminds me of advice i got when i was in
in med school where
like once you once you've done your once
you start your clinical years the
question everyone asks is oh what
specialty do you want to do and the
honest answer for the vast majority of
people is i don't freaking out i have no
idea like you know there are those odd
like weirdos that i've decided on the
age at the age of three they want to be
a neurosurgeon yeah um but for most of
us it's like honestly i don't know i
just want to kind of get a feel of
different specialties and kind of
um and the advice that one of one of the
consultants who i really respected gave
me was that like honestly just pick
something and stop moving towards it
because then you will start doing things
that will build up your cv and you'll
start actually finding opportunities
your way and then if you want to change
your mind it's much easier to change
direction when you're moving forward
rather than when you when you're
stationary and you learn about yourself
as well what do i like and what do i
what do i dislike which you won't do if
you're just if you're still kind of
standing still so kind of you know did i
write about what should you do if you
have no idea what you want to do in the
future where where a lot of young people
are and actually people who you know and
who are later in life and again it's
really about thinking what do i kind of
like doing now so let's do some more of
that and move towards the goal and then
on the way being really reflective am i
enjoying these tasks or am i just doing
it because i like the idea of becoming a
surgeon or becoming a lawyer or becoming
another job title and i really want
people to move away from the second you
know i kind of think with the future of
work
we have this disruption where people who
are able to
kind of pivot know what their skills are
job craft which you might which you've
mentioned already it would really stand
to them
yeah so it's like you're moving away
from being and more towards doing
being a doctor versus like what does the
day-to-day of practicing medicine
actually look like and does this sound
like the sort of thing that is my idea
of fun right now and i guess
i guess like it's it's kind of you know
there's that thing in in the research
about it's it's hard for us to predict
what will make us happy in the future
but it's a reasonable first
approximation that the sort of stuff i
enjoy doing now like talking to people
like you or like making videos is likely
to also probably make me happy in the
future and if it doesn't then well i can
just change course yeah this is like a
grid search so what what you know what
the government should have done in
covert and some governments did
incredibly well was what we call this
grid search strategy where they get new
data they update their decision making
based on the data and they're willing to
go backwards or they're willing to go
left and they're willing to go right and
always having that openness to a change
of direction and i think if we kind of
bring that into careers that you know
really we don't know our preferences
very well we've watched some tv when
we're young so depending on what you
watch that might actually ultimately
determine your career maybe you move
towards that if you have no idea but
always paying attention to am i enjoying
the tasks is it do i feel purpose if i
was doing this in five years time would
i be really really happy and that brings
us to the end of season one of the deep
dive podcast i really hope you've
enjoyed the season thank you so much if
you've tuned in for to some or all of
the episodes and thank you even more if
you've left a review on apple podcasts
you can still do that it'll be linked in
the video description or in the show
notes if you'd like to leave us a review
it really does help more people discover
the podcast thank you as well if you
filled out the mid-season feedback
survey we've used that to improve the
the quality of the podcast hopefully
moving forward uh i am taking a lot of
the advice that you guys gave for how to
become a better interviewer because this
is something that's fairly new to me and
i'm definitely on this quest to improve
as an interviewer of a time anyway just
wanted to say huge thank you for
watching season one merry christmas
happy new year and all that and
hopefully i'll see you in season two in
the new year thank you and bye